now to india and the horrific conditions
brought about by the worsening covet
outbreak
outbreak there in some areas
gravediggers are working literally
around the clock to keep up with the
staggering loss of human life
yesterday the country reported more than
386 000 new cases of the virus
as holly williams reports the real
number is likely much higher
india is in a life and death battle
fighting the same virus as the rest of
us but with a fraction of the resources
it needs
people are dying gasping for air because
hospitals have run out of
oxygen
while on the street those who can afford
it buy tanks of it to keep their loved
ones alive
i'm just heartbroken i just can't
explain but i get a call every
you know 20 minutes about someone that i
know or you know their parents or
someone who's dying
professor ramanan laksminarayan is an
epidemiologist
who we previously interviewed in 2018
for 60 minutes
while india's official death toll is
just over 200
000 people he believes the real figure
could be six
times as high more than twice that of
the us
right now you don't need the numbers you
could just have to go out into delhi the
smoke is thick in the air it is just
uh it's just constant it's just constant
he's talking about
india's crematoriums where funeral pyres
are now burning
24 hours a day and there's no end in
sight
less than 2 percent of india's more than
1.3 billion people
have been fully vaccinated it's not just
india it's bangladesh it is
it's africa there are hidden epidemics
everywhere is the west being selfish
looking after its own people vaccinating
its own people and not thinking about
india
no one is safe until everyone is safe
and i think we need to
really think about that as our guiding
principle
for cbs this morning holly williams
london